The general description, on
the other hand, is more general and ultimately, it's more
powerful in a mathematical sense.
In this description, quantum states are represented by a special class of matrices
called density matrices,
and more general class of
measurements and operations can be described including
noise, for instance.
It's entirely consistent with
the simplified description and in fact, you can essentially view
the simplified description
as a special case of
the general description, and it also includes classical information as a special case.
It's also really quite
beautiful in how it all works, so I strongly encourage you to learn about this general description
when the time is right, but the simplified description is the more natural place to start, and so that is what we will do.
We're going to begin by talking about classical information with an eye on the aspects
of classical information that are most relevant
to quantum information
and the way that it's
described mathematically.
Imagine that we have a
physical system or a device of some sort that stores information.
We're gonna give this system the name X, but there's nothing
important about this name.
We could use any other
name if we preferred, but just to pick a name,
we're gonna call the system X.
We're gonna make an assumption about X, which is that there is a
finite set of classical states that X can possibly be
in at any given moment.
Here, when I refer to a classical state, I mean a configuration of the system that can be recognized and
described unambiguously
without any uncertainty or error.
Really, this is something that you can think about intuitively. At a mathematical level, we simply define the
set of classical states,
we choose it however we want to or in whatever way best
describes the device that we're working with.
Let us give the name sigma to
this set of classical states, and again, let me emphasize
that we're assuming that sigma is a finite set.
The set of classical
states of this system X is not infinitely large like
the set of all natural numbers.
It's finite, and that's just an
assumption that we're making.
For example, it could be that X is a bit, in which case, the classical state set is the set containing two
elements: zero and one.
Sometimes we refer to this
set as the binary alphabet.
Another example is that X is
an ordinary six-sided die, in which case, the classical states are the numbers one through six.
Of course, we're talking
about an abstraction here.
An actual six-sided die may
have many different attributes such as its precise
position, its orientation,
its temperature, and so on. But with respect to the information that's most typically relevant when we're talking about a six-sided die,
the classical states are
the numbers one through six indicated by the number of dots on whichever side of the die is facing up.
If X is a switch on a
standard sort of electric fan that you might have in your home, then perhaps the classical states
are the settings high,
medium, low and off.
These are just examples. We could imagine systems having different classical
state sets than these, but hopefully, they convey the idea
that this notion of a classical state is something that should be
familiar and can be understood in simple and intuitive terms.
Mathematically speaking, the set of classical states
is just a finite set, and of course, this set must
also be non empty as well.
There has to be at least
one classical state that the system can be in and there has to be at
least two classical states
if the system is going to be useful at all for storing information.
Now, in some situations, we might know that X is
in some particular state, but in many situations,
that arise in the setting
of information processing, there may be uncertainty about the classical state of a
system at a particular moment
so that each possible classical state has some probability associated with it.
For example, if X is a bit, then perhaps it's the case that X is in the classical state zero
with probability three quarters and it's in the state one
with probability one quarter.
We're going to refer to this
as a probabilistic state, and we could express
this probabilistic state, as you see right here,
simply by indicating what
the probabilities are for the different classical states.
A more succinct way to express
this probabilistic state is by a vector, specifically the representation
that you see right here
is a column vector, and this vector indicates
what the probabilities are for the two possible classical states.
To be more specific, the first entry indicates
what the probability is for X to be in the state zero, and the second entry tells
us what the probability is
for the system to be in the state one. This is simply the natural way to order the binary alphabet,
or at least, it's the way that
we are trained to do this. With zero first and one second.
Going forward, we're gonna use
the term probability vector to indicate a vector like this.